one and you are live good morning
everybody it's time for me to open the
public inquiry uh my name is Matthew nun
and I'm the inspector that's been
appointed by the Secretary of State to
conduct this inquiry and to determine
this appeal the appeal is made by Kates
B strategic land limited and it concerns
the refusal of planning permission by
molden District Council for a
development comprising an outline
application with all matters reserved
except for means of access from steeple
Road and Burnham Road for a residential
development of up to 160 dwellings
including affordable housing 10%
Bungalows 100 square m of Office hub
floor space 1.21 sorry no
0.221 hectares of land for children's
day nursery and Associated parking use
Class E a community park sustainable
drainage system and Associated
infrastructure on land north of the
Groves in Burnham uh in latchington
um in Essex um that is the revised um
description of development um we
discussed uh some minor changes at the
case management conference to the
description which involved increasing
the percentage of Bungalows from five to
10% amongst other things but the given
the they they were M very minor in uh
scope um we agreed that uh we could
proceed on that basis and I understand
the council um has proceeded to consult
on that basis as well is is that that
correct yes I would confirm that's
correct thank you so just uh before we
get into the main part of the inquiry
just a few preliminary matters um
formalities just to go through um before
I explain how we will proceed today and
on subsequent days first of all can I
ask people please if they could turn
their telephones off or put them on
silent mode so we uh don't get any
disturbances during today's proced
seedings um I wonder if a representative
of the council could advise uh on uh
emergency exit should should we need to
exit the building um yes sir um we have
the exit there there's also exit that
way uh I'd also confirm that there's no
planned um fire alarms today thank you
thank you very much so if the alarm
sounds then we all need to uh leave the
building um the event is being live
streamed streamed I understand um so
that people who aren't here today um can
observe proceedings in the comfort of
their own homes if they so wish
um so I hope everyone is happy with that
um if they're not please let me
know um in so I'll I'll come now on to
um who we have appearing at the inquiry
today um first first of all perhaps I
will turn to the appellant and I'll ask
the appellant to introduce themselves
and also uh for uh me to be advised of
the witnesses to be
called good morning sir uh my name is
canuk excuse me c a n o c k initial G
for Giles I am King's Council from
King's Chambers I'm instructed by Jeff
Armstrong through the scheme of direct
professional access and I have three
Witnesses Jamie Roberts dealing with
affordable housing Charles milest
dealing with the impact on the identity
of latchington and Jeff Armstrong
dealing with planning policy and the
planning balance thank you Mr kuk uh
that is clear and for the
council so good morning my name is Luke
Wilcox I'm a barrass from Landmark
Chambers the only witness I'll be
calling sir is Mr David Coleman so
appended to my opening statement which
I'll circulate in due course there's a
list of the the relevant qualifications
who's instructing whom and so on so that
you'll have that in writing thank you Mr
Wilcox um that's clear um in terms of um
those wishing to speak I've been
provided with a list of of people who um
wish to speak um what I'm proposing to
do is to hear those persons after we
hear the opening
submissions of the main party so I will
shortly ask the main parties first the
appellant and then the um Council to
make their opening submissions which
sets out the main arguments of of the
each side's
case
um in terms of um
the proofs I've been supplied with I've
had proofs from the appellant from Mr
Armstrong Mr Roberts and Mr
milc um and from the council I've had a
proof from Mr Coleman um I think that's
all I'm expecting I have not I've I've
had no
further proofs um just to say that I've
read the proofs and I would expect them
to be taken uh largely as
red um I've also received statements of
common ground on uh planning matters and
on housing land Supply as well um just a
general point that I would make at this
stage um all the documents and evidence
should have already been
provided
um should be before me I don't wish to
receive any further late evidence unless
it's absolutely necessary um if I am uh
asked to accept any evidence I'll need
to be satisfied that it's relevant um
and I'll need to seek uh party views on
whether it should be accepted or not um
and and of course the problem with late
evidence is it may require an
adjournment of the inquiry uh to allow
myself and also others the opportunity
to read it and that can of course have a
a risk of
costs in terms of the site visit um it's
normal procedure to make a an a an
formal inspection of the site in due
course um I I'll arrange that uh in due
course um I just need to make it clear
to everybody that the site visit is
solely for me to um observe the physical
characteristics of the site in the light
of the evidence that I've heard um there
will be no discussion about the merits
of the case on on site so any points
that people want to make should be made
here in the in this room in this forum
rather than on the site visit um so I
hope hope that's clear to everybody
um now in terms of how I intend to
proceed today and over the coming days
as is as probably everyone is aware this
is a formal public inquiry so its
purpose is to test the evidence in order
to enable me to fully understand the
issues um so that I can reach a decision
on whether to allow or to dismiss the
appeal and for everybody to put across
their points um in an ordered fashion so
I'm proposing to run the inquiry in the
following order um when I've concluded
my opening remarks I will invite the
main parties as I say to make brief
opening submissions uh Mr kuk will go
first and then uh Mr Wilcox um and this
will hopefully enable everybody to
understand the main arguments of each
side um as I said I'll then hear any
interested parties um I've been provided
helpfully with a list of people who I
assume are objecting to the proposal um
and um it's obviously very important
that interested parties can participate
if they wish to do so I'm very aware
that this is a a very controversial
scheme um I observed uh a number of
people um in front of the council
offices who were obviously concerned
about the development so I I I saw that
as I as I came in um so I am very aware
of the concerns that have been raised
I've read people's objections of which
there are many um just to say to
everyone um I don't need to hear the
same evidence um many times over um so
you know a point uh repeated isn't
necessarily a point better made um so
just to assure everybody I have read
everybody's objections um and there's no
need to repeat material um but by all
means you know draw draw my attention to
anything specific that you want me to be
aware of
um once we've heard so once we've heard
the opening party submissions and we've
heard the objectors we will
then uh hear the evidence of the main
parties I.E the council and the
appellant um I propose to follow the uh
this the traditional order of the
council having its evidence heard first
and then the appellant um and as
discussed at the uh case management
conference that we had a few months ago
um I'm expecting the evidence to be
heard in the conventional manner I.E um
by formal presentation and
cross-examination um is that what Mr
will Cox you're nodding I I I I am
nodding say yes M uh my friend and I had
a discussion last night and we we'
reached the same conclusion sir yes yes
you're happy with that Mr can absolutely
sir thank you yeah um so as I say formal
presentation so that means that each
side presents a witness and then the
other side has the opportunity to
cross-examine that witness that's how it
how it works in essence um and then um
we move through each um witness um in
the order that each side wishes to call
their Witnesses um obviously Mr WLX
you've only got one witness so you have
a limited choice in terms of the
in which you you you take your uh your
witness um but Mr canuk did you have any
particular order you you were planning
to call your
Witnesses um yes sir uh two points if if
I may the first concerns the evidence of
Mr
Roberts and um Myan friend and I uh I'm
grateful to him as as you would expect
and to those listening this is a
perfectly usual thing that that
Advocates do to just try and manage
inquiry time as best as possible um he
doesn't have any questions for Mr
Roberts M Mr Roberts your recall is
dealing with uh affordable housing need
Supply affordability issues like that um
that being the case he he's content that
that evidence is taken as read that that
being his position sir I I don't
particularly feel the need to call him
formally as it were just to to go
through an examination in Chief a
document that you've indicated you've
read and that I can draw out some
Salient points with Mr Coleman and en
closing submission so so I don't need an
answer now but if you could consider
sort of during the course of the day
whether you would have any particular
questions for Mr Roberts um but but if
you don't sir then it may be that I
don't need to call him at
all that's the first point the second
point is the order would if he's
required be Mr Roberts Mr milest Mr
Armstrong right um so Mr Roberts Mr milc
and Mr Armstrong okay
um well I have thank you for that uh Mr
kak uh if if the council has no
questions to put on matters of
affordable housing um to uh Mr Roberts
is that correct Mr WX so yeah yes that
is correct Mr Robert's evidence uh for
for your purposes as it were feeds into
the waight to be given to affordable
housing and on that matter the planners
are agreed yes so on that basis so it it
seems a disproportionate use of inquiry
time AB I'm I'm all in favor of saving
inquiry time so I'm more than happy um
to take that evidence as read um and and
I don't see that it would be necessary
in those circumstances to call uh Mr
Roberts for foral
uh evidence if if that if the parties
are are happy I'm cont yes I it seems to
me that the issues that of concern to
Residents is more um obviously there are
many concerns but I I'm not sure that
the the finer details of affordable
housing um provision across the burrow
is necessarily foremost in people's
minds I think it's more obviously the
effect on the character and appearance
of the area the the effect on local
services people are concerned about and
traffic and so on so forth those kind of
issues so I I'm I'm happy to proceed on
that basis um if if if that's agreed
with the parties well so I'm really
grateful for that of course we we'll
hear from interested parties and and
maybe members this morning if something
gets thrown up then perhaps we'll
revisit that but certainly then as
things currently stand my intention
would be not to call Mr Roberts and to
inform him accordingly thank you
thank you for that Mr kak um right
um once uh I've heard the substantive
evidence of the um of the parties and
indeed of people attending who want to
to speak um we'll then have a Roundtable
discussion I say Roundtable that's it
means it's not a formal um
cross-examination process um it's merely
a discussion about conditions um that
could be applied to any planning
permission in the event I was minded to
allow the appeal um just to assure
everybody this is part of the the normal
process with with these kind of events
we always discuss um conditions um in in
just to be clear as to what what uh what
could be put on any permission if it
were granted it certainly doesn't
indicate that I've made my mind up on
this appeal or or that I've prejudged
the case it's merely a process that we
go through and similarly we we will also
have a discussion about the planning
obligation um which uh I believe um has
been provided in draft form i' I seem to
I'm recall seeing a copy of that I don't
think it's been finalized yet um
obviously that sets out um obligations
that the developer would undertake to
provide were the appeal allowed um so
again that's a normal part of the
process it doesn't mean that I prejudged
this appeal uh I have to be with both
the conditions and the um obligation I
have to consider both against the
relevant regulations and government
policy um I H hesitate to raise the
issue of costs and I'm not necessarily
wanting to get into that now but if any
party does want to make an application
for costs um they should do so before um
I close the inquiry um I'll I'll leave
it there uh for the time being just to
say also I do have the power to award
costs myself um if I feel the need um
and then right at the end of the process
I will hear closing submissions for for
all the main parties um so I will hear
from Mr Willcox first and then Mr canuk
uh which is essentially a summary of
each other's case Okay so that's how
things will proceed over the next few
days we have um four um days programmed
whether we will need the full four days
I don't know in the light of
um the number of witnesses I don't know
if anyone has any thoughts on that Mr
Wilcox sir I I I strongly suspect and I
rather hope that we can be done in three
given that that they're only going to be
three Witnesses now requiring to be to
be examined and only three interested
parties wishing to speak yes my my hopes
uh would be that we could get through Mr
Coleman today yes so that he can be
released by the end of the day I'd
certainly like to avoid him uh remaining
in evidence overnight that that would
obviously be some inconvenience to my
team if so we can get through Mr Coleman
today we should I think be able to get
through Mr milest and Mr Armstrong
tomorrow yes I don't have a vast amount
for Mr milre either much of his evidence
goes to landscape and visual issues
which I should be aware so I understand
why the appellant put the evidence in
but it's not a dispute as between the
main parties no so that that being so so
I would hope would be able to deal with
the conditions and obligations round
table on Thursday morning and close on
Thursday afternoon that it would be very
good if we could uh and I don't know Mr
kuk if you have any observations on that
uh well I'm I'm always cautiously
optimistic so and
that'ss perhaps as far as I will go but
um uh we we'll we we'll know more at the
end of the day we will we will um just
to make it clear to everybody on sitting
days I I would uh start at 10:00 uh
usually um and we would normally have a
break for lunch of around an hour and
then we would have mid morning breaks
and mid-afternoon
breaks um at a time that I would we
would be convenient um in terms of
evidence so they won't necessarily be
fixed times I think it's easier and
better to see how we get on and then uh
we'll we can take an appropriate break
mid morning and mid-afternoon
um in terms of I I wouldn't sit Beyond
5:00 um
unless there's extenuating circumstances
um and individual inquiry session
sessions I don't normally like to go
beyond one and a half hours as I think
longer periods are generally less
productive um so um just going back to
the issue of um time um I think Mr canuk
you did indicate very helpfully that you
would be about three hours with Mr
Coleman in
cross-examination um yes sir yeah um so
with any luck we we we we should be able
to get through Mr Coleman today with
with any yes and and look I'm I'm
committed to doing that um my my sort of
concern is it is a three-hour cross-
examination yeah and what I wouldn't
want to do is to try and put a a quart
in a pip pot and everyone sort of be
clock watching around about 5:00 that
when we've otherwise got time in the
inquiry now I I understand the point
about not wanting to split overnight so
I I just think you know progress today
will be determined by what progress I
understand that and and um that's why
given the very limited number of um
Witnesses really we we have don't have a
huge number of witnesses I haven't set
out a sort of detailed program as I
would on certain you know cases where we
we might have very many witnesses for
each side I I thought given the
relatively in fact it's going to be two
for you Mr canuk and one for you Mr
Wilcox it it it really doesn't seem
necessary so we'll we'll keep an eye on
things and um we'll we'll see how we get
on I'll keep you know matters in terms
of timings under close review um and as
time goes on we'll probably be better
placed to uh understand the sort of
structure broad structure of the of the
timetable as as we proceed um are there
any other um procedural points anyone
wants to raise at this
point so might I raise I've sort of got
four briefly just touching on a couple
of matters that that you've raised
firstly you raised the issue of
consultation yes um so
so minor Amendment to the description of
development uh without prejudice to our
contention consultation wasn't required
a consultation exercise was undertaken
my instructions and understanding is
that there was one response to that
consultation from the parish council and
it was identical to a previous yes um so
so Prov you have that sir yes uh the
second point is the section
106 um we're very grateful to the
assistance of the local planning
Authority we have a document which is
agreed as between the two of us of
course as you've said sir entirely
without prejudice to their contention
that consent should be refused but we
have an agreed section 106
obligation um we have half a chance sir
of getting that signed and dated by the
end of the
inquiry
um but subject to you having had an
early sight on it because obviously we
can't do that if you're going to require
some amendments and equally sir there
there is the opportunity for my
instructing slizer to who's drafted the
document to be here for the round table
session again if you think that that is
helpful so so can I just ask you to
consider those two matters um but but
otherwise I'm hopeful that that could be
a relatively straightforward Round Table
session with a document that's agreed
that all parties understand that that's
what I'm sort of angling for if that
helps yes um that leaves then uh a sill
compliance statement now there are no
contributions within the section 106
which are actively contested if I can
put it that way but that does then mean
that there's an issue as between you and
the local planning Authority as to
whether they comply with the statutory
and the planning policy tests
um we
have well we we have perhaps I could
just characterize it as a concern about
the bus contribution and so we've not
seen that s compliance statement but so
I wouldn't want anyone to think that
that's just going to be a rubber stamp
we we we would like to have sight of it
and it may be that there are some
observations in the round table so uh no
no undue pressure on the local Authority
but but self-evidently the sooner we can
see that the better and that my fourth
point so which is conditions we had a
set of draft conditions I think attached
to the officer recommendation because
that was for approval um if the local
Authority are wanting something
different on reflection then as soon as
we can get those we can work through
those again on a without prejudice basis
to make that session go as smoothly as
possible so so it would be helpful to
know if we're sort of expecting an
updated list of conditions or or or or
or what the position is there thank you
sir thank you Mr kuk um I'll come to to
Mr Wilcox in in a a minute um thank you
for confirming the issue of the
consultation um I I think a letter did
go out I saw a letter that made it very
clear that everyone's objections that
had been previously made would been
taken into account in any event you know
the the the it was a minor adjustment to
the um to the to the description and um
the letter just brought people's
attention to that and um if they wanted
to make additional comments then of
course they were the letter said of
course you can but just to assure
everyone that their previous objections
would be taken into account of um so
that's that was my understanding of of
what happened in the the the the the
letter that went out advising people of
the inquiry I don't know if anyone from
the council wants to whether you Mr
Wilcox or Mr Johnson I see in my corner
of my eye there I I don't know whether
you want to speak on that
noops perhaps Mr Johnson perhaps you you
should introduce yourself because you
haven't actually formally introduced
yourself just for the purposes of people
who might be observing
proceedings okay um thank you sir my
name is Michael Johnson I'm the um head
of development management and building
control in molden
Council um I'm here supporting um our
consultant team on on on this appeal uh
I think I'm probably known to um a fair
few in here so thank you for
that thank you oh yes on the on the
um on the point of the of the
consultation it's it's it's as you
stated yes there are no further comments
on that regard thank you okay thank you
Mr Johnson um in terms of the section
106 thank you Mr canuk for what you said
I'm happy to delay formally signing that
until we've had the the the session
obviously because there may be things
arising from the round table discussion
that you know there may be tweaks that
may be needed or or or changes or so and
so on so I think it would be more
sensible to delay any I'm not going to
insist that it's completed before the
end of the inquiry I mean I'm happy to
give a week or so um to allow after the
inquiry closes understood sir thank you
so so just to take any pressure off with
that um in terms of the sil compliance
statement yes um Mr kanuk I agree um the
council will need to produce
a a statement justifying why they've
asked for certain items I I note your um
issue about the bus
contribution um and conditions indeed we
do need a draft schedule of conditions
that we can discuss at the round table
um I'm not sure what status we are with
that at the moment but um we we will
need um a a draft to be provided before
that session Mr WLOS did you want to say
anything yes so just just to assist on
those on those two points on the sil
compliance statement that's I'm hoping
going to be ready by the end of the day
it's it's work in progress sir um
similarly with the conditions we've
we're going through at the moment so
under the under the surface as it were
we're going through the the latest round
of comments on those and they'll be
returned to the to the appell as soon as
we can again I'm hoping that will be
today and uh I'm very much hopeful that
we'll have an agreed set for you so in
good time for Thursday morning thank you
that Mr um Wilcox for that
so if there are no other procedural
points anyone wants to raise at this
stage I I just outline what what I
consider to be the main issues in this
inquiry um in terms of between the um
the main parties let's put it that way
I'm very aware that um interested
parties have raised a wide variety of
matters which I'm sure when people speak
they will um make their views known to
the inquiry but the in the light of the
discussions that we had at the case
management conference and and further
correspondence from the council the main
issues as I see them these are between
the main parties are the acceptability
of the development outside the bound
um that's the first point the second is
the effect of The Proposal on the
character and appearance of the area
including the
landscape and finally the um the
planning balance as we call it uh in
planning terms where where we have to
essentially assess the pros and cons of
of The Proposal I'm aware that a lot of
residents have raised um a number of
different issues which of course I will
also have to deal with um in my decision
as well um and I will as I say I've read
everyone's letters and I'm sure people
will will be speaking this morning and
highlight particular areas of concern so
those are as I see it the main issues
that we we need to address between the
between the council and the appellant I
don't know if anyone has any comments on
that so I've recast those slightly yes
in opening but I can address you then I
don't need to take time well as I say
these are only um indicative they're not
set in stone by any means I I I I'm more
than happy to hear how you you've recast
them Mr can the simple point is um and
I'm grateful to myone friend's
indication earlier that there's no
landscape and visual impact case the
issue as I understand it is whether
there's an impact on the identity of
latchington okay so I think that that
that issue two can be recast just
slightly more precisely and therefore
save time with the evidence of Mr milr I
I I I'm as I say I'm happy to hear the
evidence and and obviously when when
I've heard all the evidence I'll
probably be better placed to firm up the
the the main issues as it were um I
think that those that that was how I
cast them in my um case management note
I think that's right so yes and like
like my le friend I've I've also
slightly recast them in in the light of
the narrowing of the issues since the
case management conference and you
you'll see that an opening thank you but
I as I I just to reiterate um I am aware
that local residents have um a wide
range of concerns that may may not have
been captured in what I've just said and
I'm that doesn't mean they won't be
considered because they will be and they
will be given full um uh I'll I'll go
through all the points that are raised
uh and and address them
accordingly all right um in which case
um I think we can um I will ask um Mr
canuk um to make his opening
statement thank you Mr
hanock so I put this down in writing so
I'll I'll go through as briefly as I can
and it may be that I don't read every
word but I thought bearing in mind I
understood that there would be some
local resident interest I thought it was
helpful to perhaps set out some matters
in a little DET I think it is uh um
certainly Mr kuk so that everyone is
aware of you know the appellant
arguments I'll I'll number this document
um id1 as as inquiry document number one
for administrative purposes thank you uh
thank you sir the context for this
appeal is the national imperative to
boost significantly the supply of
housing there's a recognition from
central government that the planning
system is simply failed to deliver
sufficient homes for a protracted period
of time and this can no longer be
tolerated the housing crisis exacerbated
by inflation riding bills costs repeated
rises in interest rates and the cost of
living a daily news story has been
expressed most recently in the white
papers fixing our broken housing market
and planning for the future this is a
national imperative which has a clear
local expression since the adoption of
the local plan in 2017 The Authority has
repeatedly failed to meet the plan's
minimum annual housing requirement Andor
its planned trajectory against which
there is a significant shortfall The
Authority has repeatedly failed to
demonstrate a 5year supply whilst The
Authority can currently demonstrate an
agreed 5.9 year Supply it can only do so
because of its significant Reliance on
Greenfield housing sites outside
settlement boundaries re and because of
a reduced local housing need applying
the standard method additional Green
Field housing is therefore required to
maintain the 5e supply and meet the
minimum housing requirement across the
plan period further the need for
affordable housing is acute the latest
assessment is a net need for 209
affordable homes 2020 to 2040 which the
council are failing to meet by a
significant margin consequently lower
quartile affordability has risen
exponentially such that even modest
housing is 11.67 times income and
unaffordable to vast SES of the local
population this is the antithesis of
national policy which seeks to boost the
supply of housing to meet up-to-date
objective needs of all in that context
as officers have expressly recognized in
the technical review of the plan the
allocations have failed to deliver as
planned and the plan policies are too
restrictive to allow sustainable
development as a result the council have
been and remain
significantly dependent on Greenfield
sites outside the settlement boundaries
of sustainable settlements to meet their
urgent need for more market and
affordable housing this is a proposal
which delivers the significant benefits
of more Market homes 50% affordable
homes 10% Bungalows to assist in meeting
the needs of older people with
substantial economic benefits on an
accessible site immediately adjacent to
the settlement of latchingdon on that
basis the application was unequivocally
recommended through
approval The Proposal concerns an
outline application for up to 160 new
homes of which 50% will be affordable
and 10% Bungalows all matters are
Reserve saved access access means the
point of access and not the internal
Road layout 5.87 hectares of the site
would be Development Area including
Gardens and parking areas 4.25 hectares
of the site would comprise public open
space and green infrastructure including
a community park ecological enhancement
area foot and cycle paths strategic
landscaping and suds and the appeal
proposal comprises the essential
following elements and so I'll skip
through this if I may up to 160 new
homes 100 square meter Office hub
provision of land for children's day
Nursery retention of the existing World
War II pill box a mix of dwellings two
to five beds 50% affordable housing 10%
Bungalows the provision of a new
community park a sustainable Urban
drainage system the retention of
important trees Woodland and HED RS in
the site and on the boundaries with
enhanced landscape planting to reinforce
the landscape edges to the site new soft
Landscaping features within the
development new vehicular pedestrian and
cycle accesses from steeple road to the
north and Burnham road to the South a
policy compliant level of car and cycle
parking the reduction of carbon
emissions in line with the submitted
sustainability statement and electric
car charging points The Proposal does
not comprise eia development the plans
for determination are agreed and the
illustrative master plan shows one way
in which the above proposal could be
accommodated it's agreed that the
reserve matters could deliver a high
quality design on the site and the
authority no longer allies on conflict
with policies D1 and
H4 turning then to the determination by
the council at the time of the
determination there were no outstanding
requests for further information from
the authority and no technical
objections from statutory consules which
could not be overcome by condition and
planning obligation the application was
recommended for approval it was however
refused by members for a single reason
so I've set that out and you'll be
familiar with it uh article 35 of the
development management procedure order
requires that reasons for refusal must
State clearly and precisely their full
reasons for refusal and the reason for
refusal as is noted in the CMC note
raises a single objection the location
of the site outside the settlement
boundary the reason for refusal makes no
reference to amongst other things the
accessibility of the site the
sustainability of latchington or the
impact on the identity of latchington
such matters fall outside the resolved
position of the
authority whilst reference was made to
the impact on infrastructure in the
authority statement of case this was a
addressed at the CMC and the authority
have subsequently and helpfully
clarified that we are no longer pursuing
the infrastructure point in the absence
of objections from statutary consules
and that is reflected in the statement
of common ground and in that context sir
then the main issues reflect the single
issue of the reasons for refusal firstly
whether the proposal complies with the
development plan secondly the
acceptability of development outside the
settlement boundary thirdly the effect
of the proposed Al on the identity of
latchington fourthly the benefits of The
Proposal fifthly whether material
considerations outweighed the agreed
conflict with the development plan and
those main issues fall to be determined
in accordance with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise and so far as relevant the
development plan comprises the molden
local development plan 2014 to
2029 but sir given that the appellant
accepts that there's a conflict with
policies as 1 S2 and S8 the determining
issue is whether there are material
considerations which outweigh such
conflict there's a powerful consensus of
professional evidence between the
appellant and the professional offices
of the council that consent should be
granted on that basis and it's submitted
that significant weight should attach to
such a consensus of professional
evidence and then sir I turn to the
development plan and the housing
requirement the plan was adopted in July
2017 it runs for 50 years between 2014
and 2029 and whilst the plan is more
than 5 years old it's not been the
subject of a statutory update and
accordingly its policies remain extent
the housing requirement in policy S2 is
a minimum of
465 new homes 310 dwellings per anom the
housing requirement had been up uplifted
from the submission draft of 294
dwellings panim for two reasons firstly
to address out migration from London and
second ly the more fundamental issue to
address the requirement to support a
minimum of 2,000 net additional jobs by
2029 in policy E1 and the EIP inspector
considered that 310 dwellings per anom
was necessary and Justified to support
this extand minimum level of economic
growth and job creation to meet the
requirement of
4,650 new homes the plan identified a
supply of
5,18 comprising completion
extant planning permissions allocations
at molden haybridge and burnam on Crouch
with an allowance from neighborhood
plans and windfalls the spatial
distribution of housing was essentially
to contain the majority of new housing
within and adjacent to the main
settlements on the allocated sites and
to allow a small amount of growth in The
Villages through neighborhood plans and
the windfall allowance and on that basis
the settlement boundaries were drawn
tightly around the existing the 2014
settlements and allocated sites and the
spatial strategy to 2029 was therefore
simple to promote housing inside the
settlement boundaries on allocations at
the three main settlements and to
restrain housing at lower tier
settlements save through neighborhood
plans and thereby restrict housing as a
spatial approach on sites outside
settlement boundaries because it was not
needed on that basis it's agreed that
the proposal conflicts with the spatial
strategy and spatial distribution of
housing in the development plan the site
lies outside the settlement boundary of
latchington which is classified as a
smaller Village The Proposal is
therefore contrary to policies S1 S2 and
S8 which simply preclude Market housing
outside settlement boundaries the
appellant does not accept however that
there is any tangible land use planning
harm which flows from the location
outside the settlement boundary in
particular there's no Prejudice to the
delivery of the local development plan
spatial strategy and policy S2 to and
the authority don't argue the contrary
and secondly the proposal will not
compromise the identity of latchington
within the terms of policy
s112 further it's important to note that
including that there is conflict with
the development plan there's no policy
requirement or even scope to assess
amongst other things the need for Market
housing the need for affordable housing
the need for specialist accommodation
for older people socioeconomic de uh
benefits of The Proposal access ability
sustainability of the settlement the
acceptability of the impact on the
character appearance of the area Andor
the planning balance and it follows
therefore sir that such matters must
therefore be considered separately so I
turn then briefly to the performance of
that spatial strategy whilst The
Authority claimed a 5-year Supply at the
examination in public it quickly became
clear that the authority could not
demonstrate this minimum policy
requirement and so I set out then the
5year supply
April 2020 21 and 22 in April 22 it was
3.66 years further the agreed evidence
demonstrates that there's been a
significant shortfall of
536 homes in the first 5 years of the
plan there's been a significant
shortfall of 109 homes against the
annualized requirement and a very
significant shortfall of 9914 homes
against the planning housing trajectory
equivalent to 3 years Supply the
explanation is that the failure of the
allocations to deliver as planned there
is a current 910 unit shortfall in the
planned trajectory of the allocated
sites indeed the only reason why the
shortfalls have not been even more
pronounced is because of the significant
number of permissions on Greenfield
windfall sites 633 homes have been
consented in The Last 5 Years 32% of
completions and this is significantly
above the planned windfall rate and
includes sites which lie outside the
settlement boundaries and contrary to
the development plan there has therefore
been a significant failure in the
spatial strategy of the plan indeed this
has been expressly recognized in the
Authority's technical review of the plan
which recognized amongst other things
that the plan is inflexible or not
adequately flexible there's no policy
setting out how the windfall allowance
was to be delivered the policies are not
written very clearly the policy wording
means it's difficult to obtain
permission settlement boundaries squeeze
out opportunities for windfalls
immediately outside the settlement
boundary housing outside settlement
boundaries are generally refused even
when it's adjacent to existing
settlements and acceptable in all other
regards and the settlement hierarchy is
out of date and not robust resulting in
applications being refused in
settlements which could otherwise be
deemed to be acceptable and so you will
note that those last two technical
points taken by officers have a
particular resonance in this application
in that context it's agreed that the
authority has carried out a review and
determined that an update is required
the agreed conflict with policy needs to
be considered in that
context and so I then turn to consider
the material
considerations and we contend that
there's a powerful set of material
considerations which outweigh the
conflict of the development plan and
these can be considered against the
three roles of sustainable development
in the
nppf so I turn then to the social role
and the need for Market housing it's
agreed there's a 5year supply of 5.97
years however this is not a ceiling or
cap on development rather it's a simple
policy mechanism which engages the
Tilted balance the requirement for the
authority to demonstrate a 5year supply
is the minimum requirement of national
policy set against a minimum housing
requirement further the local housing
need requirement of 279 is lower than
the extant plan requirement required to
meet the minimum economic growth job
creation Target the greed Supply is
1665 however 620 homes 37% of them are
on windfall sites without them the
supplies are mere 4.45 years of the 620
homes 523 or 31% of the total Supply are
on Green Field sites outside the
settlement boundaries it follows that
the authority can only demonstrate a
5year supply because of a very
significant proportion of homes being
consented on Green Field sites out
outside settlement boundaries further
housing land suppli is set to fall even
based on the Authority's flawed
trajectory accordingly further windfall
sites will be required if the authority
is to maintain a minimum 5-year Supply
and finally there remains a current
planned shortfall of 304 homes to meet
the minimum requirement by 2029 and
therefore consents need to be granted
now to meet the minimum need by
2029 and in the context of the plan
requirement being a minimum and the 5e
Supply being a minimum requirement it's
unanswerable that the benefits of
delivering more Market homes is a
material consideration of significant
weight turning to affordable housing 80%
or 50 uh yeah 50% or 80 homes will be
affordable the agreed 10e split is 75%
affordable uh homes and 25% intermediate
ownership the plan recognizes a
significant shortfall in the
availability of affordable homes
increasing the supply is one of the key
priorities on the basis of the schar
2014 the EIP inspector concluded that a
need of 130 affordable homes could be
met through the allocations with limited
res uh rural exception schemes such a
conclusion has proven to be demonstrably
flawed the schar 2014 actually
identified a net need figure of 2011
affordable homes per anom from 2014 to
2019 154 2014 to
2029 but and the figure of 130 took no
account of meeting the significant
backlog accordingly the need in 2014 was
154 affordable homes per anom the
council's latest objective analysis
demonstrates a total net need of 209
affordable homes per anom or
4,180 between 2020 and
2040 the local housing need assessment
acknowledges a notable need and
encourages housing delivery to be
maximized where opportunities arise to
address this important and pressing
issue the re reality is that such a need
will have to be delivered by market
homes on viable Green Field sites
outside settlement boundaries in the
plan period to date The Authority has
managed just 581 affordable homes net or
65 affordable homes per anom this is
less than half of the identified need
performance is well ver against the 2021
requirement the shortfall is 305
affordable homes in just 3 years it's
clear that the delivery of affordable
homes has been
abject The Authority has identified that
it could deliver 499 affordable homes in
the 5-year period on that basis the
shortfall would exceed 1,000 affordable
homes the plan will unanswerably fail to
deliver the required level of affordable
homes to meet the objective need further
or alternatively there are 981
households on the housing register and
each one represents a household in need
now finally as a result of the failure
to deliver enough market and affordable
housing house prices have risen 18%
since 2014 the ratio of lower quartile
house prices to lower quartile earnings
is now at
11.67 rents have also increased the
average age of a firsttime buyer is now
approximately 40 years old it follows
that housing has become unaffordable for
a vast s of the local population it
follows that the weight to be attached
to the benefits of delivering 80
affordable homes to meet the identified
need without public subsidy is
substantial 10% of the homes will be
Bungalows uh and the planning practice
guidance National guidance states that
the need for specialist accommodation
for older people is critical the
demographic Time Bomb has a local
expression The Authority specialist need
supplementary planning document states
that
67.3% of the population growth will be
in the over 65s The Authority therefore
recognizes that it's a priority to meet
their needs which are considered to be
acute Bungalows are recognized in
national and local policy as being a
form of specialist accommodation to meet
such acute needs there will be they will
further free up under occupied family
homes and the benefits of delivering 16
homes capable of meeting the acute need
is a material consideration of
significant weight it's agreed that
latchingdon is an established village
with a number of services and Facilities
it's agreed these facilities are
accessible by for cycle and public
transport and further the heel are the
housing and economic land assessment and
the officer report consider that the
site is accessible and suitable for
residential development and the reason
for refusal does not suggest the
contrary in terms of the sustainability
of the settlement in recognition of the
failings of the previous assessment the
rural facility Studies have been updated
it's an objective assessment that's
intended to form a robust basis for
decision-making it concludes that
latchington is a larger Village and it's
the fourth most sustainable larger
Village in the light of this assessment
the authorities proposed to reclassify
latchington as a larger Village in the
emerging plan it follows that the site
lies in an accessible location adjacent
to a sustainable settlement indeed such
a conclusion is consistent with the of
consent on two sites immediately
adjacent to the site the site specific
he are and the officer report there are
no unacceptable impacts to
infrastructure and highways which cannot
be addressed by conditional 106 and it
follows that very significant weight is
derived from the social role of
sustainable development in terms of the
economic role the application has
demonstrated the socioeconomic benefits
of the proposal and they're not
contested I set those out briefly sir uh
these economic benefits are an important
material consideration in support of The
Proposal consistent with previous
decisions in the mppf paragraph 85 they
should be afforded significant weight
and it follows that the proposal derives
very significant support from the social
and economic roles of sustainable
development in terms of the
environmental role it's agreed that
there are no adverse impacts in respect
to flooding noise air pollution or
Heritage turning to the community public
open space 4.25 hectares of the site
would be multifun and publicly
accessible public open space that is 42%
of the site it will be managed and
maintained in perpetuity it will include
informal open space a kickabout Area
Youth provision allotments and two
children's play areas it responds to
deficiencies identified in the
Authority's green infrastructure
strategy and is supported by the nppf
imperative to achieve healthy inclusive
and safe places which encourage Healthy
Lifestyles this is a very significant
New Era of open space which be available
to existing and proposed residents and
is a benefit of significant weight and
such a large area will allow for an
agreed significant net gain in
biodiversity with a biodiversity net
gain of
30.418820 is to the identity of
latchington
on that point the site is not
internationally nationally or locally
designated it's a non-designated site
it's not a valued landscape it has no
statutory status nor identified quality
in the development plan it's not
therefore protected by mppf 180a further
it's common ground that there's no
objection on landscape grounds it's also
agreed that a high quality development
can be delivered at the reserve matter
stage and that there is no impact to
resid presential amenity the sole issue
is whether there is an unacceptable
impact on the identity of latchington
within the terms of policy
s112 the appellant submits that the
proposals would protect the settlement
character and identity of lingon as its
experience from the approach is to it
the broad linear character of the
settlement rule Remain the existence of
the village as a settlement within a
predominantly agricultural landscape
will remain indeed the new settlement
Edge will improve the interface between
the raw settlement Edge comprising the
rear of modern housing in the
countryside to the east the extensive
areas of public open space and high
quality Landscaping will provide an
attractive and valuable feature for new
and existing residents in effect the
proposals would move the Modern Edge of
the village eastwards into an area of
unremarkable agricultural land which is
already heavily influenced by the
existing modern settlement Edge the
proposals would in fact soften the
integration of the settlement into the
landscape and provide a visual
Improvement to the way in which the
proposals relate to the countryside it
follows that on balance the proposal
represents sustainable development and
complies with the framework which
strongly supports it and that is a
further material consideration in
support of the proposals and it follows
sir that material considerations
outweigh the conflict with the
development plan and it's therefore the
appellant case that permission should be
granted subject to the conditions in the
106 thank you uh Mr kuk for that um I'll
ask uh now for Mr Willl Cox to deliver
his opening statement on behalf of the
local Authority thank you very
much I'll number this for the purposes
of the inquiry as
id2 I'm wondering whether these
documents can be um uploaded to the
council's website um so that uh everyone
who wants to see them can um given the
limited number of copies that that would
be appreciated if that could be I'm sure
that can be done say yes thank you it's
certain W be done by me but I'm sure
someone on my side is is able to deal
with
that sir thank you very much I I I must
begin by apologizing for the state of my
voice I'm afraid I'm emerging from a
horrible cough so sorry for being horse
and croaky and if I Collapse into a
coughing fit I'll apologize to the fans
for that as well
so the Appel and six outline permission
is as you know for up to 160 dwellings
with all matters reserved safer access
on lands the north of the Groves burnam
Road latchington I'll call them the
proposal and the site respectively so
the site is an undeveloped Greenfield
location in the countryside adjacent to
the Eastern edge of latchington village
on 14th of June 2023 the local planning
Authority refused permission for the
proposal the basis of that decision is
reflected in the single reason for refus
us which I set out so the essence of the
council's case is this the proposal is
contrary to development plan will harm
the character and identity of
latchingdon as a rural settlement and
there are no material considerations
weighty enough to justify departure from
the development plan
conflict turning so to the main issues
and the nature of the disput as you
identified in your opening sir your case
management conference note identified
three main issues for consideration
they're set out and I I won't read them
so since the CMC the dispute between the
parties has narrowed somewhat the
following points of agreement are worth
noting at this stage one the parties are
agreed that the district can demonstrate
9 uh forgive me 5.97 years housing land
Supply so that the development plan is
not out of dat in mppf terms two the
planning Witnesses appear to agree that
the development plan is consist
consistent with the latest iteration of
the mppf subject to a minor point about
policy sa which I'll explore in
evidence three the council's confirmed
it doesn't take a landscape or visual
objection to the proposal four the
council no longer relies on development
plan policies D1 or H4 as grants for
refusal essentially because they're
policies which will become relevant at
the reserve matter
stage five the planning Witnesses are
agreed that the proposal is contrary to
policies S1 S2 and S8 as cited in the
reason for refusal and six the planning
Witnesses appear to agree that the
proposal is thereby contrary to the
development plan as a
whole so given that extensive agreement
the dispute between the main parties is
now really very narrow it turns on two
main questions one does the proposal
harm the character and identity of
lingon and two are the planning benefits
sufficient to overcome the presumption
against development which conflicts with
the development plan
turning to the policy framework the
local and National policies relevant to
the appeal are agreed and are set out in
the statement of Common Ground as you
have seen it's worth emphasizing at the
outset of the inquiry sir the absolutely
Central role of the development plan as
the driver of development decisions in
the locality in particular it must be
recalled sir the development plan has
legal priority over the mppf I set out
there so what well known quote from Lord
Justice Lind Blom in the Hopkins homes
case which confirms that
point the Central purpose of the
development plan sir is also stressed by
the mppf itself paragraph 12 of the mppf
notes that developments which conflict
with an upto-date development plan as
this one does should and I quote not
usually be granted that important
principle sir must be borne in mind
throughout the next few
days turning to the policies so the
parties agreed The Proposal conflicts
with three development plan policies
policy S1 is the district sustainable
development policy it establishes a
number of key principles to be applied
in development control
decisions those principles include
delivering growth in the most
sustainable locations and maintaining
the rural character of The District
without compromising the identity of its
individual
settlements policy S2 provides the
spacial strategy to meet development
needs and is the site allocations policy
for the district it's agreed that the
appeal site is not allocated for housing
or indeed for any other form of
development nor is the proposal wifall
development or supported by neighborhood
plan policy S8 establishes the
settlement hierarchy and boundaries and
sets a framework for the protection of
the intrinsic character and beauty of
the countryside it does so by
establishing a test for when development
will be permitted Beyond settlement
boundaries and that test is in two parts
one the development must not have
versally impact on the character and
beauty of the countryside and two the
development must be one of a wide range
of types which are recognized by policy
as supporting a sustainable rural
economy it's Common Ground sir that the
proposal is not within any of that wide
range of permissible development
types turning to the main issues sir
main issue one the suite of up-to-date
development plan policies in this case
which I've just described establish a
clear framework for considering the
suitability of developments in the
countryside the purpose of that
framework is to protect the intrinsic
value of the countryside and to restrict
rural development to the kind that
benefits and supports the rural economy
the most relevant policy for this
purpose is S8 which sets out the
comprehensive test I've described for
addressing such proposals as already
explained that test has two limbs policy
compliance is dependent on both limbs
being satisfied it's Common Ground here
that the second limb is not satisfied so
the policy test is
failed so that is not a technical breach
as the appellant suggests the plans
framework is the result of the detailed
Democratic process of local plan
preparation and
examination that process resulted in a
decision that proposals such as this one
are unacceptable in locations such as
this one in a plan-led system sir that
decision is not a technicality it goes
right to the heart of the acceptability
of this
proposal main issue two concerns the
impact on the character of latchingdon
latchingdon so under the plan is a small
village some 500 dwellings that retains
the essential linear character which has
defined agricultural Villages of this
size and in this location for
centuries the development would increase
the number of homes in lendon by by
around
33% and would increase the area of
development in the settlement by about
53% it would compromise the agricultural
setting of The Village as well as its
historic linear form such a dramatic
increase in the size and shape of the
settlement will obviously have an impact
on its character and identity it's hard
to see so how it
couldn't that impact is exacerbated yet
further when it's considered on a
cumulative basis with the 162 dwellings
which already have permission to be
developed beyond the lingon settlement
boundaries since the start of the plan
period in 2014 those permission so were
largely as a result of the former
historic Now application of the Tilted
balance in the Malden
District furthermore so the development
would have an indisputable impact on the
site itself turning it from agricultural
Fields into a busy modern housing estate
with the associated light noise and
vehicular movements as well as the
introduction of a large amount of new
built form again sir it's hard to see
how that could not impact on the
character of the
settlement it's worth noting sir that
the council's concerns here and the
concerns I've set out are not landscape
and visual ones the L andv impact of a
scheme is relevant to its impact on
settlement character but it's not
decisive in this case the relevant harms
arise irrespective of the landscape and
visual position which is why the
council's not called a landscape of
visual
witness turning sir to the planning
balance perhaps the most important
factor in the planning balance is the
party's agreement that the proposal is
contrary to the adopted development plan
the key relevant policies of which are
up to date the starting point and
legislative presumption therefore is
that the appeal should be
dismissed are there material
considerations which outweigh that
conflict or to use the language of the
mppf is the proposal unusual enough to
be permitted despite the development
plan conflict the council so will sh
show through its evidence that the
answer to those questions is no The
Proposal undoubtedly delivers planning
benefits but these are nothing out of
the ordinary for modern housing scheme
in that regard it's critical to recall
that the council can demonstrate a
healthy housing land supply of 5.97
years now I accept that the housing land
Supply figure doesn't represent a cap on
housing delivery in an area nevertheless
where an authority has a healthy Supply
as this one does then the presumption in
favor of the devel elment plan applies
with greater force than where there is
no 5year Supply the mppf itself proceeds
on that basis so as you'll be well aware
the Tilted balance is not engaged in
cases like this
one one area where the proposal's
benefits go beyond that of generic of a
generic housing scheme so as in respect
of affordable housing we recognize that
in providing 50% affordable units The
Proposal exceeds the 40% policy
requirement we also recognize the
pressing need for more affordable homes
in the market alen area so that's why Mr
Coleman as you have seen from his proof
has attached substantial weight to this
factor in his planning balance the same
as Mr Armstrong has for the
appellant the fact that an area needs
affordable housing does not however
justify delivering that housing in the
wrong location the council will show
that the site is simply not the right
place for these houses the plan-led
system will see the required homes
delivered in the right locations without
the need for proposals which are
contrary to
policy and finally within the planning
balance there are a number of dis
smaller disputes around the waiting of
various planning benefits they'll be
exploded evidence But ultimately sir
those are matters for your
judgment in the final analysis so the
appeal boils down to a simple issue is
there sufficient justification for
Fairly ordinary Housing Development to
take place in a location which is not
supported by the development plan the
council will show that there there is no
such justification and on that basis
we'll invite you sir to dismiss the
appeal and refuse permission for the
proposal thank you very
much thank you Mr Wilcox uh for
that
um I'm I think I'm going to take a short
break uh shortly um but I just wanted to
check um before we hear from um those
who want to speak about the develop M
members of the public just wanted to
check how many people actually do want
to speak on this list I have
here I I just have three people one of
which is Anthony Fitzgerald Peter en
twistle and councelor fitk um are those
people
here they're all here right are there
any other people that want to
speak I'm not the problem is is is that
I I'm I'm aware that some people
probably aren't actually in this room is
that correct they're in an overflow room
and therefore um they're not going to be
able to answer me um so what I think
would be a good idea is is um is to
check during the break if we can just
check to make sure that there are no
other speakers that want to address the
inquiry um and and if if I mean if there
are other people of course they're I'm
more than happy to to hear from them
um so if if we can do that during the
break that would that would be helpful I
I'm not quite clear where the other
people are are they fairly nearby or
they are right good
okay
um my understanding is people didn't
want to sort of come and go and disturb
you see that that's why they're in the
other room that's at least my
understanding yes cuz I mean there are a
few spaces here if people did did want
to attend but that's fine um if we can
if we can just check that there there
are no other speakers um in in the Break
um and then and then we'll we'll hear
from those speakers um so we'll have a
it's now 25 minutes past um 11 we'll
come back at uh quarter to 12 okay so
the live streaming should hopefully
terminate um thank you just over now
and
um so you're live again thank you very
much
um uh as I said before the break um I'm
proposing to hear from public speakers
uh and any counselors as well that that
wish to to address the inquiry um so far
I have the following Anthony Fitzgerald
Peter Entwistle councelor fitk and
councelor stamp um do we know whether
there were any other people that wanted
to
speak no all right well in I I mean in
no particular order apart from those the
way they're listed on my list
um I'm happy to hear from Mr Fitzgerald
first if he wants is Mr Fitzgerald here
if Mr Fitzgerald if you could come up to
one of the chairs where there's a
microphone um and uh address the inquiry
I should say that strictly speaking the
opposing side presume I assume you're
speaking against the
development yeah strictly speaking Mr
kanuk um one of these chairs I should be
fine Mr kanuk does have the option of
asking questions um of you uh Mr kuk I
don't know whether you're proposing to
exercise that option um in my experience
often barristers let members of the
public speak um you know unless there's
some very specific point that they want
to um ask yes I'll adopt that style of
approach sir yeah thank you Mr K that's
helpful subject to questions of
clarification or or egregious statements
yes in indeed
quite okay uh so uh Mr Fitzgerald if you
if you'd like to um just introduce
yourself and um if you can say whether
you're in favor or against I assume
you're against and if you're a local
resident perhaps you could just give an
indication as to where you where you
live that don't have to give the exact
details but just the the general
location would be helpful no problem
okay good morning everyone is still
morning um my name is Anthony fitgerald
I'm a resident of Laing Road in
latchington I represent the um the
residents of latchington
um protest group The nimes as we were
earmarked in
the in the uh in the media these days
ridicul ridiculed in the media in in
some some circles um we're the people
that actually live nearby the people
that actually work nearby we're the
people that that that it's going to
directly affect where we live and how we
live
um you was pointing out earlier that um
just is just a point that was made about
about the the visual impact on the
village uh when you do your site visit
sir um I would urge you to come down
from mland and just just look at look at
the Village coming down from Island
you'd see the church the steeple the Big
Sky that would have a visual impact by
putting putting that development where
you're proposing to put it a massive
massive impact if you can imagine
something in the in of the ilk of uh
elely
Cathedral um you can see it from
everywhere Latin and church is a little
bit like that as you approach it from
the East
um so it would definitely have a visual
impact um now you were stating about
professional um Prof professional
uh what's the word I'm looking for do
you know I've never sat in a probably
inquired before so please excuse me I'm
you know I'm quite good at speaking it's
just it's fine um um you're professional
opinion um the only professional opinion
that I can offer you is that of a
professional Road user I'm a transport
manager I've run
uh road hoage vehicles for most of my um
most of my career um so I'm I'm pretty
good with with roads um and one of the
things that I will tell you is that the
road in and out of lingon where it
converges
um at the end there at the mini
roundabout by the church um if you'd
like to go and look at a website called
e6s
air it gives you the air quality right
at that Junction right where them two
roads converge which is where there's a
primary school and the air quality is
medium that is comparable of that of
underneath the Dartford Bridge medium
air quality in a rural Village right
next to a primary
school I think that you know if you if
you um if you go ahead with this
development you're only going to add to
that um more traffic equals more bad air
quality but but if you look at the whole
of the denji 100 on that map that is the
only place where there is medium air
quality where the traffic converges and
the reason the traffic converges there
is because if somebody Parks outside the
shopping lingon the whole of the D would
pretty much comes to a
standstill um and that's fact so every
morning there was a nice big queue
through
lingon
um yeah you know and and we're just
going to add to that if we add more
houses just going to add to it um yeah
so all I can do is talk to you as a
resident you know as I say lived in
latchington 36 years in the same place
in Laing Road um and this proposed
development is going to certainly impact
my
Outlook um it will probably um stop me
from being able to use my property in
the way that I've previously enjoy using
my property so from a personal
standpoint and not just myself I know
that other residents of lendon have also
got the same problem um because we we're
totally un overlooked at the moment
um yeah so going forward if that changes
and I can tell you now I can report to
this Council now that one resident uh of
of Laing Road has moved out has moved
out of the house the house is a vacant
in Laing Road it hasn't been sold yet as
a direct um result of of this proposed
development so we're going to be moving
people wholesale while a look of it uh
if it goes ahead but there you go um
yeah nothing else to add really any
anybody anybody want to ask me any
questions um thank you Mr fitzgeral for
for making your concerns uh heard uh
just to reiterate what I said earlier I
I am very aware of the concerns that
local residents have have have about
this proposal I I've heard well I've
obviously heard what you what you've
said this morning but I'm also I've read
a lot of letters of objection as well so
so I you know be be assured that that I
I am aware of those concerns yeah
wonderful so so um unless you have
anything else to add um I I've noted
what You' said um and uh and that so
that's fine yeah anything else I've got
you've got him writing anyway so yeah
indeed okay well thank you uh Mr
Entwistle for for your cont 's over
there sorry uh Mr Fitzgerald Mr
Fitzgerald I I
apologize yes Mr 's next on my list I I
do apologize for
that good morning sir good morning
committee and again can I apologize I'm
not familiar with speaking in front of
all you know the Committees are like
this and also I actually thought it
might only be allocated two minutes so
you'll be pleased to know that my
comments are very very brief uh there's
no this given this is a public inquiry
uh unlike a a council meeting um we we
we don't usually impose such no sure
stringent requirements but brevity is
always
appreciated yeah well as you said in
your earlier comments which we very much
appreciated we we don't need to go over
all the objections and complaints that
you have received because you obviously
rece read them and they've been noted
and taken into consideration and also we
don't have the um the background for
laws rules regulations and
technicalities that you know Kate's
being and these guys so that's that's
not really our our point to come across
I can only really speak as a resident of
Laton for 24 years I live on the Burnham
Road um so before I uh when I moved in
we we we didn't have any of the four or
five developments that have gone through
in latchingdon so we've seen the the
visual impact of of how the village has
changed and especially how the traffic
has uh
increased um
my points and those bought earlier in
the other committee and those by the
others were 100 agreed by the 24
committee members as as we know voted
240 last time those local committee
members are people that live in the area
they understand the area they know how
the denji works and what's the
implication the road Etc
are what I say to catsby I understand we
need development we need to grow we all
understand that we understand this but
it needs to be done in the right place
filling up Villages and places that are
poor Road quality is not the answer to
our problems um
um I live in live on the denji burnam
southminster and all the other villages
to the east of us are building hundreds
if not thousands of houses and this is
the one point that I really wanted to
bring to you sir because I know you've
got many
comments of those three um all those
areas in the denji there are only three
roads that come off and as Tony pointed
out two of those roads meet at the very
point that you are trying to build this
development um of those two roads the
residents already endure heavy traffic
congestion long cues and often uh long
delays for 2 hours in the morning and in
the evening this is now happening in the
day and at weekends are we really going
to build a large development at that
very spot it's almost beyond belief and
I know I'm obviously quite passionate
about it but are we really going down
that route to add to this as Tony said
there's a primary school that was built
locally many years ago for the local
residents that that that primary school
is on that very
Junction um the developers as I say they
have to bring potential sites we get
that but clearly they haven't looked
into the homework and have shown their
complete lack of knowledge in the area
and I I say that you know in in in my
personal opinion
um if it wasn't for the farmer being
dangled you know the pound signs in
front of him he would agree with the
very comments that we are all making
it's just that obviously you know
Finance talks as I said in the last me
meeting I obviously don't agree the 24
committee meters me Members didn't agree
and um we can only talk as as locals and
residents in the area thanks for hearing
me and is anything who would like to ask
me and apologize for my blumberg
ways uh no Mr enst thank thank you very
much uh I don't think Mr canuk you have
any particular points do you no thank
you thank you Mr thank you thank you
very much thank you Mr
nistle six out of 10 I got right okay um
then the next person on my list who
wants to speak is uh councelor fitk is
councelor fitk
here
uh thank you chair I'm councelor Tony
fit I'm chairman of Lon Parish Council
chairman of the denji H group of
parishes and District counselor for the
orthorn ward sorry can I just take a
note you say so you're a district
councelor and a a local counselor a
parish counselor chairman of the Lin
Parish Council chairman of the denji H
group of parishes and District councilor
fully author mod okay
so for the for the ward of latchington
yes
yeah okay the author World covers
lington althorne mundon and
Meeny okay thank you thank you
so I've sort of had to change what I'm
going to say I I guess based upon some
of the information that's been provided
to you via the um uh applicants for the
development it would seem that a great
deal of Stories being placed on the case
um for the need for affordable housing
within the district and the 2021 local
housing need assessment that indicated
that we'd need was 174 affordable rented
or social houses per year and 35
intermediate rented at that point in
time it is true to say that the district
had not really provided very many
affordable houses um and and given that
position the assessment concluded that
um in order to meet the local housing
need um it concluded that it it
basically matched the the plan Target of
310 it came out at 308 which included a
49% uplift in affordability to help with
affordable housing the assessment also
concluded that in order to meet a
requirement of 522 houses per year to
afford that 209 Target would be
inappropriate and that the the the
number of houses built should not be
influenced by the market Market houses
um it's just a false mechanical
reference if we were however to look at
the situation now in 2020 three when we
did the um uh FY housing land Supply
assessment the affordability ratio had
actually improved and therefore we only
need a 42% uplift so on the one hand in
2021 it was
11.87 11.71 I think this year it was
10.87 so are we really saying that over
that period of time afford ility has
improved well obviously it
has the assessment makes it very clear
that it's an assessment over point in
time you can't use it project forward or
backwards it's an assessment as it was
then and part of that assessment will be
the inclusion of relets and at that
point in time the relets are only 50
well given the fact that we hadn't built
very much affordable housing up to that
point in time you could reasonably
conclude that that number would be
significantly different now because in
the last couple of years or three years
we' built over 500 of aordable houses so
I don't really think that looking back
at data that historically been provided
is going to really give us very much of
a a forecast of what's required in the
future there's much reference in the
report and and and the planning document
to substantiate the departure from the
local development plan based upon an
officer opinion on how the development
plan is progressing well again you can
look at these numbers in various
different ways yes it is true that we're
not meeting the plan trajectory set out
in the development plan but a plan
trajectory was not anything other than
the ability to try to predict the point
in time that we'd need infrastructure
now originally the primary
infrastructure required was the
expansion of plume which was expected to
be in 2019 2020 well it's fair to say
that these strategic sites have
developed slower than was originally
forecast but I think it's also fair to
conclude that we did have a pandemic in
the middle of it now that undoubtedly
had an effect on on the delivery of of
of the spectal plan and it was reflected
by the government in its reduction
within the hous in delivery Target
measurement to of three months on one
month to show that there was some impact
on development so again I I'd say that
we can use numbers in whichever way we
want to use and I really think we should
focus on what we need for the future
rather than what has happened in the
past moving forward we have according to
the
2023 local uh
AMS we've got around about 5,900 consent
when you include uh kabang burn and wers
phase three in it against the plan
Target we'd build around about 2,800 so
we still have Circa 3,000 houses that
have been approved left to develop we
have about 7 years say 5 years six years
of the plan the the standard method now
indicates 279 so we have plenty of
future supp Supply over and above the
plan requirement I think it is fair to
say that it has been Green Belt
development approved throughout the plan
process but you could also argue that
was done the position of tilt and it was
required to make sure that we've got
sufficient future Supply which we do now
have the most significant development
yes was a significant development that
was Greenfield but that was for
specialist housing for the olderly
people in burn and Walter some 600
houses so in terms of where we are the
development plan arguably we're pretty
much on target now at the last
assessment using the pr plan Target we
would be 109 houses behind the required
amount over the plan period if you look
at the projection for this year we're
going to actually exceed that position
and it looks like we're going to do to
to do so moving forward so personally I
feel that we're in a very strong
position as a local Authority in terms
of our delivery of our local development
plan and the future moving forward so
where does that leave us when I joined
the council one of the first things I
attended was a planning session and
within that planning session there was a
slide and on that slide um it it
basically said this why do we have a
local development
plan and members were asked to think
about the matter and the answer to that
from the uh the um person that was
presenting was that and it was a man
looking over a field at his fence open
field to provide certainty to Residents
was the answer that the consultant gave
us on that matter so why do we have a
local development plan we have a local
development plan because it's agreement
as I see a contract between ourselves
the government and the residents with
respect to how many houses will build
over a period of time and where they
will get built and by doing so there is
some certainty to Residents that if they
buy our property in a certain location
and for businesses if they wish to
develop their business that there will
be some certainty of what will happen
next we're left in a position whereby
because of situations that have Arisen a
development has come forward that sits
outside of the local development plan
and therefore it clearly does not Accord
to the spal um shape that that the
members set out in agreement with the
government in agreement with the
residents and we're asked to depart away
from that
well it's interesting to note that in
the recent review of the MP PF the
government has made great efforts to try
to ensure that local development plans
are better protected moving forward I'm
sure so you are aware that in many
appeals significant challenges will be
um uh undertaken by applicants
challenging the 5 hous in land Supply
position um especially when it gets
towards the end of a plan and in
formation of a new plan because it'll
always revolve around the interpretation
of some moding judgment I would say how
how long will things take to build and
at what speed will they build out there
well nobody really knows the answer to
these questions but we seek to answer
that question by putting all of this
data onto a spreadsheet that then
informs us as whether or not our plan is
sound well our plan is sound we have
5.97 years when we look at the changes
to the mppf it's very clear that we'll
be moving soon towards uh the spectal
shape that would allow require us to
only demonstrate a fouryear housing land
Supply when we reach the regulation 18th
stage and on adoption of a local
development plan there'll be protection
for the district against falling below
the 5y housing land supp for a period of
5 years after adoption so given the fact
that we've got 3,100 consents already
sitting out there um and that the
government are looking to allow the
councils to include over Supply in in
future 5e housing land Supply positions
unless something significant happens the
council really is in extremely strong
position so why did the government make
the changes to the the
mppf despite great opposition from
developers because it sees the value of
protecting the interest of residents and
ensuring that residents are actively
involved in any consultation process
well it might well be in the fullness of
time that as we move forward as a
district council and we determine what
our spectal approach should be on
whether L remains a large Village
becomes a medium Village or becomes a
small AG are matters to debated by
members at the appropriate point in time
and decide based upon an evidence-based
approach
accordingly we may or may not decide
that the location that this applicant is
is proposing is the most suitable to
meet that growth requirement that we
determine for the future and that will
be determined by what the responses we
get from the residents and the members
according not by developers and not
necessarily only by office so I really
do feel
that if if we do allow departure from
the plan for for really technical
reasons such as affordable housing or
social economic benefit then what's the
point of having a local development plan
in the first place because every single
development that comes forward will
offer exactly the same
benefits so where what what what's the
differ between this one and the other
one there'll be no point having plans so
I really would urge you sir to dismiss
the because I really don't see that the
benefits of
departure outweigh the significant
departure from the the local development
plan thank
you um right uh thank you um thank you
councelor fic you you did raise quite a
lot of detailed um information in that
uh your your your submission there I was
wondering whether it would be helpful
certainly for me um if you could
do a sort of summary of what you've said
in writing and and and put it into the
inquiry because I you you did make a
number of De quite detailed points um
and I think it would be helpful to have
those in writing um rather than you know
to make sure that I captured I'm I'm you
know that I've got everything before me
that you said because you you did as I
say there was a lot there is that
possible you could do that indeed it's
probably already done actually so I just
going you that would be helpful and and
and we'll put that in as an inquiry
document so so that it's before the
inquiry I'll just check to see whether
Mr canuk wants to ask you any questions
um Mr kuk
um I don't sir no thank you uh there
there are a number of points and what I
might call technical points about
numbers and things but I'm going to pick
those up with Mr Coleman in due call so
um whilst obviously I I don't accept
what was said I don't want to duplicate
matters and I don't think you thank me
for putting the same matters twice so so
with that sort of caveat now I've got no
questions no uh thank you Mr kuk that's
helpful as I say it would be helpful um
councelor if you could if you could just
put put it doesn't need to be a lengthy
note but just essentially summarizing
what what you've just said that would be
really helpful for from my perspective
certainly thank you okay councilor fit
thank you very
much and then councilor
stamp thank you
thank you councelor stamp if you just
introduce yourself and uh I'll let you
uh thank you sir thank you everybody um
my name is councelor Wendy stamp I'm
juel hatted at the moment I'm a county
counselor and I'm also a modern District
counselor S I wasn't going to speak but
I I uh and hopefully you will indulge me
because what I want to say Mr Coleman
won't be surprised that what I want what
I'm going to say because at the EIP
appeal hearings when the our original
ldp was heard I spoke a great deal on
education well I know it is not the
statutory consult te as ESS County
Council I'm not speaking on their behalf
I'm speaking on my behalf is the local
represent local representative who has
to deal with many many issues when we
get uh overdevelopment and
infrastructure that isn't actually
keeping Pace with the number of houses
that seems to be uh developed and built
out so what I'd like to say Sir is that
we know ESS County Council is a
statutory uh has a statutary duty to
provide places in mainstream and outside
mainstream education which is for
children who go to the uh local primary
schools secondary schools and also I'm a
massive advocate for send provision um
you may not be interested to know but
I've marched in Downing Street to try
and raise awareness for the lack of
provision in this area we don't have any
special schools out here uh in the
modern district and more appropriately
in the dangi where this development
would go looking at the number of houses
that is looking to be approved and 50%
affordable that inevitably will um
include houses and families with um
houses including large families which
will put uh um a weight and a pressure
on the school places as I said Mr
Coleman heard me speaking at the
original in
where Mr keyock was the education person
for essit County Council and I was
actually a member of the public to
public who referred to as Mrs stamp and
I wasn't a counselor but it inspired me
to actually stand and become a counselor
because my forecasts even though they uh
the inspector acknowledged they uh most
probably were accurate but because um M
do I call you Mr nun um
sir um with Inspector Inspector it's is
sadly come to fruition I in front of me
have the upto-date school school figures
and shortages of school placements
around our area now some of you won't
know but this development where it's
going to be yes there is a primary
school and yes there is some um places
left but when if you come to the other
side where parents still have a choice
sometimes of people going into to school
places um we don't have such a vast
choice for our senior School our
secondary schools
uh and through hard work we've managed
to get a couple of for mes at orston
plume is bursting at the seams I can't
remember who actually mentioned about
the expansion of it uh but it isn't
coming in time with all these
development councilor fitk actually
spoke the best that you'll ever hear
about figures he's an absolute godsend
to to um understand data and be able to
explain it fully and openly to everybody
so they can all understand it um my main
concern is that if you do allow this um
development where it is the school
places won't keep up whether or not as
it's County Council they they can't you
know for a fact inspector they can't
refuse it they can only take Financial
contributions because that's how the law
Works correct me if I'm wrong I'm sure
the barristers will if I'm incorrect
there and I apologize if I've misled the
uh uh the inquiry um so your law is
going to have a contribution now we know
there is a huge lag of those
contributions being delivered in this
District so if yet again we have this
this you see Fe see fit to approve this
appeal we're just going to be back to
square one we don't have enough School
places out here and we know that the
County Council has said that there has
to be a minimum of 4,500 in the next
plan to be able to get a primary school
in the
area now that actually won't equate and
won't keep up with the other
infrastructure defic deficiencies we
actually have have so whilst I know it's
not a reason that you're considering I
would actually ask you to cons think
about it about the impact of where this
development is going to be the impact on
the schools around it because the
children will not be able to walk to
school yes they might be able to walk to
the primary school they can't walk to a
secondary school they will be busted
Essex County Council is is looking at
resources so we all know that they not
be providing the transport that most
probably is necessary which then will
result result in the number of cars
going on the road which actually was it
Mr Fitzgerald who said about the cars or
whoever said about that Junction on
lendon my biggest post bag inspector is
about that lendon High Street the we've
got a um uh a uh road closure coming up
which everybody's absolutely dreading
because it absolutely brings the denji
Burnham and the the other roads to a
standstill once you've got a road
closure for Road works now they have to
be done but what you've got to
understand and you will understand it
when you get there when you go out to
the site is we usually have a one one
Road in One Way Road out if this
development Mr inspector was at the
other end of the village I don't think
there'd be so many people who was
against it all the development that's
taken place so far is the wrong end of
the village it should be where the other
main roads are and you've got other
roads coming in and out of of the
district and the DJI
so I haven't got anything else to say
but thank you for allowing me to speak
and I'd like to thank um the residents
for actually being brave enough it's not
easy to sit and St uh sit and speak at
one of these inquiries but hopefully
you've listened and read all the things
as what you've said so thank you very
much thank you councilor stamp for that
um as I say um I I'm I'm very aware of
the concerns of local residents and and
I've heard what people have said this
morning and uh I appreci iated is a
rather formal business public inquiry
and and sometimes people find it you
know difficult to make the points but I
think everyone's made their points very
well this morning so that's fine and of
course I've got the large number of
letters that people have written as well
so that's fine I've got no further um Mr
kanuk I should ask you of course whether
you whether you had any questions of Mrs
stamp coun no no I didn't so can I can I
though just to to to assist you in
considering some of those points give
you a reference uh I'm not quite sure
where you are with the core documents
but it's CD so core document 2.1 it's
the officer's report it's section
4.4.3 and this is where it deals with
education primary education secondary
education in in particular School
transport contributions but this is a
matter that we'll be looking at through
the S compliance statement in the
section 106 in Du course so perhaps I
can just give you that note and leave it
there thank you Mr kuk I appreciate that
the official position of the council is
that they haven't raised objections in
in respect of what we might broadly term
infrastructure education and so on is
that's my understanding of the situation
I appreciate that counselors and local
residents may may not their views may
not align with that position but uh that
the C the council's official position
position is that they haven't raised
these concerns um as such um yes sir
being slightly pedantic about it neither
the council as local planning Authority
nor Essex as educ as the local education
Authority so there's a consensus between
the two understand that Mr K thank you
um okay fine um right just before we we
finish this part of the inquiry just to
to make sure the these are the only
people on my list that I've I've um had
requests to speak are there any other
people that want to
speak no all right well thank you all
very much for your contributions um and
we'll we'll move on to the next stage of
the inquiry which which in fact is the
formal evidence stage um as I said
earlier we we'll hear the council first
on that now um it's 20 last 12 um I
don't know Mr Wilcox how long you might
be in Chief with your witness well sir
I'm I'm not planning to have Mr Coleman
read out anything uh because you've read
the proof and I'm not sure it will it
will assist you so I've got a few pages
of questions just to expand on some of
the some of the key points and to to
draw out the main threads of evidence i'
thought I'll be in the region of 45
minutes so right
um well we have two options we can
either break for lunch now have an early
lunch um and hear chief after lunch or
we can start Chief now um well so I I
think my slight preference would be to
have an early lunch if that's right of
course under the new know professional
guidance indeed I'm aware of this new
professional guidance which essentially
says that um whereas previously um
people weren't restricted as it were
after chief um they are now as I
understand it under these new
professional guidelines I think strictly
speaking they always should have been
but the practice slipped but well but
yes I don't want to condemn Mr Coleman
to a lonely sandwich so no perhaps this
is the solution no uh Mr K do you have
any observations on that yes sir my my
preference would be to we've got 45
minutes now before 1:00 to hear to hear
the examination in Chief and then from 2
till 5 we've got 3 hours of cross
examination my my my concern is that
otherwise we're going to have 4 hours of
evidence sort of uh with with maybe
potentially a sort of 10-minute break in
between and that's that's that's quite a
heavy afternoon which which I will do uh
but I think that's less preferable to
starting now so that's what I would
encourage you to do but I'll I'll abide
by whatever you tell me the problem is
Mr K with with these new rules that
we've got um in some respects
I my view is that if people are in Chief
then I can't really see what the problem
is them not you know being in what we
used to call purda but um but those are
the rules are are the rules well
guidance as as as as it is um perhaps so
a a a helpful solution would be to take
a slightly shorter lunch and a slightly
longer afternoon
break yeah so so as to perhaps if we
take 40 minutes for lunch and half an
hour break at an appropriate point in Mr
K cross examination okay that that might
be the that might be the way to so we
take a break now then take a break now
come back at 1:00 I'll get going we'll
get straight cross and okay um all right
well we'll do it that way then um we
we'll we'll we'll we'll do it that way
we'll we'll have a we'll we'll we'll
break until 1:00 and then we'll hear
Chief and then we'll have a short break
after that so if we resume then we'll
we'll J now and we'll resume at
1:00 um so so so might I
be